Now I'm going to walk you through the
process of getting your workspace set
up on Windows.
There are also written instructions
in the instructor's notes.
If you're using Mac or
Linux you should skip to the next video.
First I'm going to configure git
bash to use a white background.
If you prefer to use a dark
background you can skip this step.
I'll click this icon, select
Defaults and go to the Colors tab.
Then I'll set the screen background to
white and the screen text to black.
Then I'll close and reopen Git Bash and
the screen is white now.
Next I'm going to download
two files that are needed for
the setup I showed you earlier.
One to enable tab completion, and one to
enable the git features in the prompt.
The links to these files
are in the instructor's notes.
To download each file,
I'll visit the page,
right-click anywhere on the page,
and select Save as.
I'll save the file to
my Downloads directory.
Next, I'll use Git Bash to move
the file to my home directory.
My home directory is where I
start out when I open Git Bash.
Or I can move to it by
typing cd ~ if I need to.
Now I'll use the command
mv which stands for
move to move the file I just
saved to my home directory.
Now the first argument is
the file I want to move,
which is in my Downloads directory and
it's named git-completion.bash.txt.
Now the .txt was created by the web
browser, but I don't actually want that.
So I'll choose the name
git-completion.bash as the new name.
And without specifying a directory it
will automatically get saved to my
current directory.
Then I'll go through the same
process to save the second file in
the instructor's notes as git-prompt.sh.
Next I'm going to create a file
called .bash profile which
contains configuration for Git Bash.
I recommend using the configuration file
that I used when filming this course.
To do this you can download the file
called bash_profile_course in
the downloadables section.
Then use Git Bash to move the file from
your Downloads directory or wherever you
downloaded it to, to your home
directory and name it .bash_profile.
Don't forget the dot at
the beginning of the name.
If you already have a bash profile,
then don't run this command.
Instead you can copy and
paste the content from my bash profile
into your existing one if you like.
I don't see any changes to my prompt yet
and that's because I'll need to
close and reopen Git Bash
before the changes take effect.
I'll do that at the end of the video.
In case you're curious about what's in
this batch profile, or if you'd like to
pick and choose which lines to keep,
I'll go through what each line does.
Don't worry if you don't understand
how each line works though.
Even experienced UNIX programmers
frequently copy and paste this kind of
thing from their friends,
rather than writing it from scratch.
This first line loads one of
the files you downloaded earlier, and
enables tab completion.
These lines define some colors,
which will be used in your prompt.
This line loads the other file you
downloaded earlier, and it's necessary
for the git related stuff, like commit
IDs, to show up in your prompt.
This line makes it so that an asterisk
will show up in your prompt if you
change something in a git repository.
And this line sets the prompt.
It will show your user name in purple,
the commit you have checked out and
other git related stuff in green, and
the directory you're currently in
followed by a dollar sign in blue.
Anything after that will be
displayed in the default color.
If you're curious to learn more
about how prompts work in bash,
check out the link in
the instructor's notes.
But it's not necessary for
the rest of this course.
Now I'll configure git to
use Sublime as my editor for
things like commit messages.
You'll want to configure git to
use whatever editor you like, but
the process should be similar.
First, I'll need to figure out
where Sublime was installed.
For many people this is under
C:\Program Files\Sublime Text 2.
And that's the case for me.
If it's not here, you might also try
looking under C:\Program Files (x86).
Then I'll run the command git config
--global core.editor followed
by the text editor that I
want to use in double quotes.
For me, this is Sublime, and I'll need
to specify the full path to Sublime.
But for now, I'm just going to
type sublime as a placeholder,
followed by -n -w.
The -n means Sublime will
open in a new window and
the -w means git will wait for you to
close Sublime before trying to continue.
Now, I'm going to replace sublime with
the full path to Sublime in single
quotes, starting with
the directory you saw earlier, and
then I'll add sublimetext.exe.
I know you can't see
the whole command here.
You can copy and paste it from the
instructor's notes, although you'll have
to modify it if Sublime is installed
in a different location for
you, or if you're using a text
editor other than Sublime.
It's also a good idea to make sure
you can launch your text editor from
within Git Bash.
I'll show how to do this for Sublime.
If you use another text editor,
I recommend you use Google to figure out
how to launch it from within Git Bash.
I can already launch Sublime within
Git Bash by typing the full path to it,
but I'd like to have a shortcut.
To create one I'm going to add a line
to my bash profile using Sublime.
Now opening the bash profile is going to
be a little tricky because anything with
a dot at the beginning of
the name is a hidden file and
it won't show up in most
file system explorers.
To get around that I'm going to
temporarily rename the file to not
have a dot at the beginning of the name,
then I'll change it back once I finish.
Then I'll open up Sublime and
open the file.
I'll navigate to my home directory
under Computer > C:\Users\cbuckey.
And then I'll select the bash_profile.
Then I'll add this line to
create a command called subl,
which will open Sublime.
If you use Sublime, you can copy and
paste this line from
the instructor's notes.
Although again you might need to modify
it to be the location Sublime is
installed for you.
Note that this command also won't work
until you close and reopen Git Bash.
Now that I'm done,
I'll rename the file to have a dot
at the beginning of the name again.
If I didn't do this,
then this file won't automatically
be loaded when Git Bash starts up.
Next, I'll run two more Git
config commands that will come in
handy later this course.
I'm going to run them now so
that all the configuration advice for
the course will be in one place.
You can copy and paste these commands
from the instructor's notes.
Finally, I'll close Git Bash and
reopen it.
Now, I can see that my
prompt has changed.
And if I want to view my
bash profile using Sublime,
I can run subl .bash_profile.
Remember to close and
reopen Git Bash when you're finished or
your changes won't take effect.